I often hear people say man if I had
Jeff Bezos money life would be amazing
then I wish I was wealthy like Warren
Buffett or Bill Gates or Zuck or any of
these guys
Elon Musk I would love to have their
kind of money so you don't want their
money if there's anything you would want
the right answer is the following I wish
I could figure out how they think in how
they process issues if you had Elon
Musk's processor Warren Buffett's
processor you're going to make money and
by the way you're actually going to
enjoy life even more because your
processor is what you're gonna have for
the rest your life money you're gonna
run out of eventually maybe not that
kind of money look last week I was doing
a podcast and on the podcast I was asked
a very good question I said we're gonna
turn it into an episode here's what the
question was Pat if you have to do it
all over again all over again and you
had to get involved in an industry and
it cannot be insurance or financial
services because that's what I'm a part
of what industry would you choose to get
involved in and I'm gonna cover that
answer here with you in the episode in a
minute of a prior to getting into it if
you got any questions thoughts comments
comment below and if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel click on the
sub button right here to subscribe and
right next to a click on that alert
button so you join your notification
squadron you wanted to first to get the
videos when it comes out so let me get
right into the question what industry
would you be involvement if you had to
do it all over again it cannot be
insurance and financial services this
was my answer to them I said look I
don't look at industry I don't care what
industry it is I think we put way too
much emphasis into industry think about
it can you imagine if you would have
said imagine I'm doing a video ten years
ago I think the industry were you can
make 60 billion dollars just go try to
beat cab drivers you wouldn't laugh at
me if I his honesty would you have not
laughed at me if I said that go be taxi
drivers yellow cab you're gonna build a
sixty billion dollar company you would
have said I'm out of my mind so it's not
the industry it is not about the
sexiness of the industry it is not about
oh my gosh it's gotta be technology or
it's gotta be a social need it's got no
any industry clothes shoes al Bundy's
shoes Zappos a billion dollar sales a
shoe salesperson as a joke in a serious
call Al Bundy forget about the industry
here's all it is this is how you got to
think about it what can I do in any
industry pick any one of them with the
delivery of the product coming to me
it's condensing timeframes so for
instance we like uber because if I want
a cab I got to call an 800 number I've
got to wait until the operator finds a
cap then they call them then the cab
driver either shows up or doesn't why
because maybe he doesn't show cuz no
one's gonna give him a two-star or a 1
start they don't care about that kind of
stuff but an uber boom condensed
timeframes I use uber you got Netflix
convinced timeframes I don't need to go
to Blockbuster I don't want to get out
of my house change my clothes going to
public rent something decide Netflix
boom boom boom boom boom boom I'm
picking this thing everything is about
condensing timeframes right so here's a
system for it I told you I'm gonna give
you a system here's a system for it
pick an industry you're part of matter
of fact the industry you're part of
right now say you've already chosen the
industry to be a part of and let's work
with you first everybody else you can
apply the same exact thing to someone
that hasn't yet chosen the industry yet
then you can apply this to the
industries you choose to be a part of
it's actually gonna be a very fun
exercise it's a seven step process let's
go through it number one identify the
process meaning process of me ordering a
cap that is a process ordering a cab
right
buying a house I'm gonna identify the
process I want to buy a house number two
lists the praat list the steps of the
process for example I want to order a
cap what do you do call an 800 number
next the person is gonna find a cab
driver next then the cab driver comes to
me next then it comes list so number one
identify process number two identify the
steps of the process number three here's
the magical one see if you can eliminate
which one of these steps on the list why
you have no idea how many companies at
one point when they got big they started
hiring all these big resumes and they
hire the guy that came from Harvard or
Yale or Princeton to make himself seem
very important they had all these laws
and regulations and rules and all this
other stuff and they added this new
paperwork that you got to do that steak
so much time that if you eliminate it
you save a bunch of time for your guys
or whoever that's doing the business
right number four number four is
minimize one of the steps what can you
do to shorten the time line on one of
the steps so again let's go through it
again list the process number two lists
the steps of a process number three
which step on the process can be
eliminated number four which of the
steps can be shortened
number five beta tested in a small
market see how it goes
number six after beta testing come back
and revisit and see what adjustments and
pivots you can make make those
adjustments and number seven go
implement the new process that you put
together let me explain what happens
with this this is one of those videos
where you watch us and I would say five
percent of people that are watching is
they're gonna say oh my gosh I just
figured this thing out let me explain
why I'm not telling you this is not
theory like I'm not reading a book and
telling you all this is it I'm doing
this I run a business and I had a hard
time selling five life insurance
policies let me say it again I'm in the
life insurance business life insurance
business is the company that's what I do
without a degree I was having having a
hard time selling five a month last one
we saw three thousand seven forty two in
one single month why because we
constantly in our company over and over
and over and over again we go through
these processes in meetings and we say
identify the process to make a list of
the steps of this process three which
step can be eliminated for which one can
be shortened five beta tests with the
smart get six let's revisit and see how
it went to make some pivots and
adjustments and seven let's implement
this is what's made me tens of millions
of dollars because this works this can
make you so much money if you use this
either into whatever business or
industry choose to be part of or the
current industry or part of them by the
way for some of you that are saying Pat
I want to kind of go a little bit deeper
into this no problem
send me a tweet and Patrick made David
I'll give you a couple book
recommendations or maybe one at least
that you can read that can help you with
this topic
and for those of you that are saying I
wish I had this on a PDF to kind of look
at and make a list of it we got that for
you as well click on the link below
Mario's gonna put together for you a PDF
that you can download and go through
exactly with the seven steps pick two or
three of your partners for them and get
into a room and actually apply this and
see what happens I can tell you one
thing for a fact you're gonna have an
aha moment more importantly I hope you
make this a permanent way of the way you
process issues for the rest of your
career with your business again if you
haven't subscribed to this channel do so
any questions thoughts comment also
comment below take care everybody
[Music]